first things first
time to go fishing
i hope to get some some eels some eels
yeah a congo eel
we have big congo rails here of course
david wants to go fishing for
congregails
they're powerful and enormous just like
david's competitive croatian spirits
is that yours yes yes it's my beauty
that is a beautiful boat
thank you all right i'm so excited
honestly yeah you're not gonna fishing
for my
sailing boat i'm gonna fishing for my
selling boy you're going fishing with my
father
stop it in that dinghy yeah it's a
traditional way of fishing
yeah but hold on a minute this is for
joy for fun
let's talk about comfortable first is
that really your father
yeah good morning welcome good to see
you are you serious we're going fishing
in there yes
there's me thinking on this beautiful
glamorous sailboat that belongs to david
and his family
but no he wants me to become
croatian quickly should we set sail or
set sync
people told me croatia was like italy
but none of my vacations on the amalfi
coast
had me fishing in a boat not much bigger
than a bathtub
david's dad set a line of baited hooks
at dawn
to hopefully catch a congareel
just be careful for the hooks big hooks
be very careful it's a dangerous thing
this line has a hundred hooks set three
meters apart
big hooks grab the wrong spot and you've
gone from fisherman
to catch of the day a little bend on
your knees so it would be
easier gotcha it's a workout and a half
yep it's good for your shoulders
there's one on there there's one on
there yeah it's a big one
yes when you start feeling that tug all
of a sudden it's an indication there's a
conga
that's heavy on there pick it up
get up good feeling wow
that's the big one i'm talking about a
girth of your knee i mean they're thick
and they're strong and they're powerful
there's no another one there's another
one down there oh yeah it's a big one
it's a big one
good feeling that is my hussein
there's one more on here what is under
there
the tug of a congariel with a hand line
is huge you can really feel that thing
fighting you that's heavy on there
there is that adrenaline because you're
pulling like mad and you can feel it tug
tug tug
there she comes he's coming he's tugging
like mad
this line isn't budging david says eels
here
can weigh nearly 30 pounds which is much
bigger than anything
i've pulled in so far that is massive
it's a big one
wow that's a beauty size of that thing
after my croatian crossfit workout i'm
definitely ready for a break
uh i just hope my arms have enough
strength left to lift the eel from my
plate to my mouth
we made some kung goril pate
it's silky and very tasty a little bit
buttery
i had no idea it can be finessed to that
level of a pate
it's really good our limit in the
kitchen you know it's
only in our heads an amazing start to my
journey let me tell you
i'll come back at the end of the week
and we'll cook together yeah
i'll give you a run for your money thank
you now
can you get me off this bloody boat i
never thought a congregail
could set the bar based on the flavor of
that pate
i think this guy's got other tricks up
his sleeve this is gonna be a tough
final cut
you